然后你会发现
其实大部分时候
我们都是在等而已
就是大部分时候是不会操作
不会经常去乱下单
都是等到比如说特定的形态
或是你想要等特定的时间点
这样做会比较合理一点
开盘这时候我是不会做的
我会等它如果真的要走多方
走那种很强的话
它会
它一定会有一个折坏
遮壞的時候再做多就好
或是等它形成一個區間
再決定說要不要找位置盡多這樣子
然後這種時候就會讓人上頭
就是你覺得啊
找到開爬那邊就直接追
就好
還可以吃一頓
那你要慶幸還好
這個不是實盤
試試看好了一樣1比1可以好 錯掉了我們目前沒有自動出場所以到你要停存為止
你要自己按掉
錯
然後錯完之後就上去
好那這個就是疊回開盤的這個位置
日開是這個
還蠻兇的
一拜點了
哇嗚
你在幹嘛
直接把一陣天長的都吃掉了
讓我想起了昨天跟前天的行情
打腳
反彈搶搶看
停住 走
其實這邊有一個小細節
這個是我的策略之一
就是當這種疊很兇的團你如果想要接刀的話你要怎麼接你可以去看一分K因為一分K啊以前我會做這種以前我會這種它打下去上來
我就直接進
就是看那種銀線長長的有沒有
就是很像
就是你就有個衝動想進去接刀
你去看這個銀線啊
它每次下來的時候
它有沒有慢慢電上來的那個趨勢
所以如果你在一分鐘
你看到這種就是每次下來
每次下來它就是低點越來越高
你就是找位置
不要不要進在這個上面就好
你就是吃盤上你進在這種位置
你就去賭桌它就是一個要彈一小段的走勢
那這種時候你就可以
通常可以吃到一段了
那至於要吃到哪邊就隨意
因為其實這個就是一種比較樂透的打法
所以這邊四四到九五
就是接近吃的五十點
其實已經很補了
以日內Downtone來講
50點還蠻補的
所以其實這邊就下班了
這種盤式你已經有辦法吃到50點
比如說你一般可能一天你都是吃二三十點那今天突然給你一個五十點你是要收還是不收那如果說你前面比如說在某個地方已經有獲利了
那這一段等於是你多賺的
你用不賠跟他去換更大的獲利當然是OK的
最後宣傳一下我們目前的活動
11月12到26號
我們有惠人通行證兩倍送
就是像比如說剛剛的這種融資融券槓桿的功能
或是我開雙周期圖表這種功能
還有期貨模式
因為一般免費的話
期貨模式我們會限制時間段
就是你可能只能玩到某幾天的
那如果說你想要不受限制的話
就是要使用我們的會人方案
這個會人通行真的是要用趨勢幣
那趨勢幣的話的價格就在這邊
通常你買一個月就是300元
那因为我们现在有活动
所以只要你卖趋势币300元以上的
就是直接送你两倍的周期
如果说你有想要练习胎子当中
练习打海棋打Proven
就是欢迎大家来加入我们的会员